[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis ein schönen Freitagabend
wünsche ich Ihnen im Sport blicken wir
auf die bald beginnende Fußball-WM mit
Norbert Lehmann entschuldigt unsere
großen Nachrichtenthemen
Kompromiss gefunden nach harten
Verhandlungen ist der Tarifstreit bei
den Metallern beigelegt im nächsten Jahr
gibt es mehr Geld
Kompromiss gesucht der Weltklimagipfel
muss in die Verlängerung noch immer
fehlt eine Lösung für die Entschädigung
ärmerer Länder
und wieder tote im Iran die
regimekritischen Proteste gehen weiter
Augenzeugen sprechen von
bürgerkriegsähnlichen Zähnen
[Musik]
nach einer dramatischen
verhandlungsnacht heute früh die
Tarifeinigung zwischen Arbeitgebern und
Gewerkschaft für die Beschäftigten der
Metall und Elektroindustrie da sich bei
Baden-Württemberg um ein pilot-bezirk
handelt wird der Abschluss wohl für die
ganze Branche also für rund 4 Millionen
Beschäftigte gelten und so sieht die
Einigung konkret aus die Beschäftigten
bekommen über eine Laufzeit von zwei
Jahren insgesamt 8,4% Melonen und zwar
in zwei Schritten ab kommenden Juni gibt
es ein Plus von
5,2%. eine zweite Erhöhung von 3,3%
steht dann ab Mai 2024 an außerdem gibt
es für jeden Beschäftigten 3000 Euro
netto dazu was diese Abschluss bedeutet
Sven klasse
Schichtwechsel bei Marquardt im Süden
von Baden-Württemberg am Nachmittag nach
der Einigung im Tarifstreit ein
Familienunternehmen das unter anderem
Schalter und moderne Autoschlüssel
herstellt und bei dem die Mitarbeiter
den Tarifabschluss überwiegend positiv
bewerten überraschend hoch also sind sie
zufrieden ja natürlich wir brauchen
immer mehr zum Leben und ja ich bin in
Ordnung
natürlich mehr aber ist okay der
Marquardt Chef saß mit am Tisch bei den
Tarifgesprächen die bis 3 Uhr am Morgen
gingen als Verhandlungsführer der
Arbeitgeber Gespräche die
zwischenzeitlich mehrmals vor dem
Scheitern standen wir sind aber alle
unser Verantwortung gerecht geworden so
dass wir jetzt einen für uns als
Arbeitgebern gerade noch erträglichen
Abschluss vorlegen können das ist unterm
Strich ein Ergebnis des in schwieriger
Zeit mit viel hadern mit geringen mit
viel heftigen Debatten zustande gekommen
ist hunderttausende Beschäftigte gingen
in den letzten Wochen bundesweit auf die
Straße die bereits fünfte
Verhandlungsrunde im Tarifstreit brachte
jetzt den Durchbruch ich denke es ist
ein sehr gelungener Kompromiss
einerseits werden die Beschäftigten
tatsächlich höhere Löhne haben durch den
höheren Tarifabschluss auch durch die
Einmalzahlung und gleichzeitig gleicht
es die Inflation nicht wirklich
vollständig aus an der Stelle vermeiden
wir also den großen Kostendruck für die
Arbeitgeber die Einigung gilt zunächst
nur für Baden-Württemberg soll nun aber
auf alle bundesweit 3,9 Millionen
Beschäftigten in der Metall-
anhaltenden Inflation explodierende
Energiepreise damit die rund dreieinhalb
Millionen Studierenden und
fachschüler:innen besser durch die
Energiekrise kommen hat das
Bundeskabinett entschieden dass sie eine
Sonderzahlung von 200 Euro beantragen
können im Rahmen des dritten
entlastungspaketes geplante Auszahlung
Anfang des Jahres die Kosten trägt der
Bund außerdem billigte das Kabinett mehr
Geld für den Nahverkehr mit Bussen und
Bahnen und zwar jährlich eine Milliarde
Euro mehr auch wegen des geplanten 49
Euro tickets
eigentlich sollte die Weltklimakonferenz
heute enden aber bis jetzt steht keine
Abschlusserklärung und so geht das
Treffen der rund 200 Staaten in die
Verlängerung wie lange noch offen vor
allem um die Ausgleichszahlungen an
ärmere Länder die ja besonders unter den
Folgen der Klimakrise leiden wird noch
gestritten die EU hat dazu jetzt einen
Fond vorgeschlagen aber der kommt nicht
bei allen gut an aus Sharm el Sheikh
elisabeth
es ist der vorerst letzte große Protest
dieser Konferenz heute sollte es hier zu
Ende gehen doch die Delegierten können
sich noch nicht einigen der
Hauptstreitpunkt eine Finanzierung der
Klimaschäden für klimaaktives Jeff aus
den Philippinen ein emotionales Thema
allein dieses Jahr gab es so viele Opfer
der Klimakrise in verschiedenen Ländern
auch in meinem deshalb ist es so wichtig
diese 27 Klimakonferenz nicht zu
verlassen ohne einen Finanzierungsmodell
für Klimaschäden
die armen Länder die besonders von den
klimafolken betroffen sind fordern einen
Fonds in den die reichen Länder
einzahlen ein Vorstoß in den
Verhandlungen die EU bringt sich auch zu
einem Vorschlag für einen Freund durch
wir sehen dass es Staaten gibt die keine
Minute mehr haben darauf zu warten dass
es einige gibt deswegen müssen wir an
der Seite der verletzlichsten stehen
doch eine große Gruppe von Entwicklungs-
und Schwellenländern lehnt den Vorschlag
der EU ab sie haben Angst dass der Fond
für zu wenige Länder gelten soll bisher
ist noch kein Kompromiss in sicht weder
bei der Frage wie ausreichend ein vor
oder andere Möglichkeiten Finanzierung
für die besonders verletzlichen und
jetzt schon Geschädigten Menschen
aufgebracht werden kann noch wie man das
Tempo erhöhen kann für den Klimaschutz
Klimaschutz und die Erderwärmung noch zu
begrenzen denn mit jeder Tonne CO2 die
ausgestoßen wird steigen die Kosten für
die Schäden des Klimawandels
die Hoffnung ist also dass die
Verlängerung den Durchbruch bringt bei
der Weltklimakonferenz wenn ihr heter
wie könnte einen Teilerfolg aussehen
es müsste sich erstmal dieser Konflikt
der sich jetzt zwischen den
Industrienationen vor allen Dingen
zwischen Europa und China in den letzten
Tagen aufgestaut hat auflösen die
Europäer wollen ja ganz erlaubt gesagt
dass China die Taschen aufmacht und Geld
springen lässt für diesen Klimaschäden
vor weil China ein so großer CO2
Verschmutzer ist
das wollen die Chinesen nicht das sagen
sie nicht so laut und so gerecht dieser
Vorschlag manchen eben auch erscheinen
mag in Europa für die Chinesen ist eine
Provokation weil sie sollen in diesem
Topf einzahlen aber sie sollen daraus
nichts entnehmen dürfen und ihre eigene
Schweigen zumindest öffentlich lassen
Sie über die Entwicklungsländer spielen
die dann diesen Vorschlag ja heute hier
der EU auch abgelehnt haben also wenn
die Europäer ist nicht schaffen hier
heute Nacht von rechts nach links zu
laufen und noch Entwicklungsländer für
sich zu gewinnen oder aber ein anderer
Vorschlag noch von irgendwoher kommt das
heißt die USA würden einen neuen
Vorschlag zu den Klimaschäden vorlegen
dann hat das das Potenzial diese
Konferenz zu sprengenden von diesem
Thema hängt wirklich jetzt alles ab auch
alle anderen Kapitel die hier verhandelt
werden und das ist das Problem das ist
das Problem dieser Nacht danke für diese
Einordnung winnie-
in den iranen dort gehen weiter viele
Menschen gegen das Regime auf die Straße
das reagiert mit Gewalt mindestens 360
Menschen wurden im Zuge der Proteste
bereits getötet schätzen
Menschenrechtsorganisationen und rund
16.000 Menschen inhaftiert trotzdem
haben sich die Proteste seit ihrem
Beginn Mitte September auf immer mehr
Städte ausgeweitet über die aktuelle
Lage
es brennt nachts auf den Straßen in
Teheran Mashad Rast in vielen Städten
fordern tausende junge Iranerinnen und
Iraner trotz brutaler Repression immer
lauter den Sturz des Regimes den Tod des
Diktators
[Musik]
brannte eine Ausbildungsseminar für
Mullahs und südlich von Teheran das
Geburtshaus von ayatoll nach homini des
Gründers der Islamischen Republik wie
das Regime auf die Proteste zu antworten
gedenkt machte erneut ein führender
geistlicher beim Freitagsgebet in
Teheran heute deutlich
wir fassen diese Aufständischen haben
keine Gnade verdient sie müssen sterben
seit Wochen gehen die Behörden mit
brutaler Gewalt gegen die Proteste vor
Knüppel tränengasschusswaffen
allein gestern wurden landesweit 18
Menschen getötet darunter in Israel im
arabisch besiedelten kusistan ein
neunjähriger Junge nach
behördendarstellung die Folge eines
Terroranschlags Lügen sagen
protestierende die Polizei habe wahllos
auf Menschen geschossen
Präsident reisi empfing unterdessen die
Fußballnationalmannschaft vor ihrer
Abreise nach Katar während 21
Demonstranten angeklagt vor sogenannten
revolutionsgerichten die Todesstrafe
droht im Staatsfernsehen vermitteln
Propaganda Bilder scheinbare Normalität
ein Tweet ist Außenministers deutet auf
eine ernstere Lage hin der Westen und
Israel heißt es da bereiteten einen
Bürgerkrieg in Iran vor Normalität
klingt anders
und ich sehe wurden heute die Opfer der
gestrigen Polizeigewalt beigesetzt ein
Ende des Aufstands ist nicht in Sicht
in der Ukraine greift Russland weiter
gezielt die Energieinfrastruktur an bis
zu 40% der Menschen seien inzwischen von
Stromausfällen betroffen so der
ukrainische Netzbetreiber in den
umkämpften Gebieten ist die Versorgung
teils seit Monaten unterbrochen was das
für die Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
bedeutet hat sich unsere Porter Hannah
Hebestreit nördlich von casson im
dorfpricip angeschaut
unterwegs sind die befreiten Dörfer bei
hassonnen erinnert noch vieles an die
schweren Kämpfe dieser
munitions-transport hat die Front nie
erreicht viele Soldaten die in
begleiteten hatten keine Chance Raketen
trafen sie kurz hinter dem Dorf Brigitte
auch dessen 400 Einwohner mussten häufig
Beschuss aushalten es gab verletzte auch
Tote
Angriff los ging wollte unsere Nachbarin
Tanja rosetzka ihre Kühe von der Weide
holen eine Granate ist direkt neben ihr
detoniert hinterher sammelten wir ein
was von ihr übrig war und wir haben
Tanja begraben
zusammen mit ihrem Mann Gregory hat
Katharina fast ihr ganzes Leben in
diesem Haus verbracht Strom und Gas gibt
es seit Monaten nicht mehr für ein
bisschen Wärme sorgt nur ein kleiner
Ofen
Aljona murmelt sich dick ein wenn sie
hinter ihrem Haus die Enten füttert aber
drinnen kann sie die dicken Klamotten
auch nicht ablegen
ich hoffe das ist bald wieder Gas und
Strom gibt denn wir kriegen inzwischen
nicht mal mehr Brennholz sie sagen uns
ihr müsst warten warten
also warten wir
und ihre Nachbarn haben bis zum Winter
auf ihre Befreier gewartet jetzt
brauchen Sie schnell Hilfe von den
instandsetzungs-
auch wenn sie im Moment wenig zum Leben
haben kein Gas keine Energie nicht mal
Wasser trotzdem sind die Menschen hier
froh denn die acht Monate die sie im
Trommelfeuer zwischen den Fronten
verbracht haben die sind vorbei aber mit
den Folgen des russischen Einmarsches
werden sie hier noch lange zu kämpfen
haben
fast zwei Monate nachdem mehrere Lex an
den Gaspipelines nordstream 1 und 2
entdeckt wurden haben schwedische
Behörden den Verdacht auf Sabotage
bestätigt die ermittelnden konnten an
den beschädigten Leitungen
sprengstoffreste nachweisen an den
Röhren die von Russland durch die Ostsee
nach Deutschland verlaufen waren Ende
September vier Lex festgestellt worden
tagelang strömte Gas an die
Wasseroberfläche wer für die Sabotage
verantwortlich ist ist weiterhin unklar
zu einer erschreckenden Tat in Essen
dort hat ein Unbekannter offenbar in der
nachtschüsse auf das ehemalige
rabinerhaus der Alten Synagoge abgegeben
zwei durch schlugen eine Glastür dort
befindet sich ein Institut für deutsche
jüdische Geschichte
NRW Ministerpräsident wüst sagte der
Vorfall zeige dass die Anstrengungen zum
Schutz jüdischen Lebens nicht nachlassen
dürften
es ist halb neun am Morgen als Anwohner
vier Einschusslöcher entdecken und sich
bei der Polizei melden die rückt sofort
aus sperrt den Bereich rund um die Alte
Synagoge in Essen ab ein Spürhund war im
Einsatz Sprengstoff fand er aber nicht
zum Glück wurde niemand verletzt es
wurde mittlerweile eine
Ermittlungskommission gegründet unter
Leitung des Staatsschutzes die Schüsse
trafen offenbar in der Nacht den Rahmen
der verglasten Eingangstür des Rabbiner
Hauses und durchschlugen die Scheibe die
Ermittler gehen von einem männlichen
Einzeltäter aus das hätten
videoauswertungen ergeben in den
betroffenen Gebäude ist ein Institut für
Deutsch jüdische Geschichte
untergebracht es grenzt direkt an die
alte Synagoge die heute als
Kulturzentrum und nicht mehr als
Gotteshaus genutzt wird
es ist ein Ort der Begegnung es ist ein
Ort der Debattenkultur ein Ort der
jüdischen Kultur es ist keine aktive
Synagoge aber es ist ein Ort was für
jüdisches Leben in Essen steht und
darüber hinaus nur vernehmen wir das
alles sehr ernst der Zentralrat der
Juden reagierte am Mittag bestürzt auf
den Vorfall das auf die Alte Synagoge in
Essen geschossen wurde ist beklemmend
die Alte Synagoge steht für gelebte
Deutsch jüdische Kultur die Schüsse sind
ein Angriff auf unsere gemeinsamen Werte
so Präsident Josef Schuster NRW
Innenminister Herbert Reusch sprach von
einem Anschlag Polizei und
Landeskriminalamt würden alles tun um
den Täter zu finden
er würde queren Menschen nicht raten zur
WM nach Katha zu reisen da sie nicht
sicher sein so der erste querbeauftragte
der Bundesregierung Lehmann vor allem
ging es ihm heute aber um die Lage in
Deutschland für lesbische Schwule
Bisexuelle trans- oder
intergeschlechtliche Menschen deshalb
hat Lehmann jetzt den ersten Aktionsplan
der Regierung queer Leben vorgelegt und
gefordert stärker gegen Diskriminierung
und Übergriffe vorzugehen Dominik
schepka und Jonas Wengert
Münster im Sommer Christopher Street Day
sie trauern um malte den Transmann der
zu Tode kam nach einem querfeindlichen
Angriff Max appenroth wurde mit
weiblichen Geschlechtsmerkmalen geboren
Anfeindungen gegen Transpersonen kennt
auch er
sie bekommen es halt tatsächlich zum
Beispiel über Social Media regelmäßig
mitgeteilt dass ich ekelhaft sei dass
ich krank sei oder das ist so etwas für
mich überhaupt gar nicht gibt also dass
ich ja im Prinzip eigentlich nur
irgendeine verwirrte Frau bin die die
gar nicht weiß was mit ihrem Leben
passiert um querfeindlichkeit
entgegenzuwirken hat die Bundesregierung
einen Aktionsplan beschlossen das Ziel
alle Menschen sollen gleichberechtigt
Leben damit das auch für Lesben Schwule
Bisexuelle trans- und
intergeschlechtliche also queere
Menschen in dieser Gesellschaft gilt ist
eine aktive Politik gegen
Diskriminierung notwendig konkret will
die Bundesregierung das Grundgesetz
ändern niemand dürfe wegen seiner
sexuellen Identität diskriminiert werden
Blutspenden soll für alle möglich werden
auch für Männer die Sex mit Männern
haben und queere Menschen sollen besser
vor Gewalt und Hassrede geschützt werden
z.B im Internet der Lesben und
schwulenverband mahnt dabei zur Eule aus
unserer Sicht ist entscheiden dass all
diese Maßnahmen die im Koalitionsvertrag
schon drin stand und die hier noch mal
bekräftigt wurden dass die auch noch
innerhalb dieser Legislaturperiode
umgesetzt werden es ist der erste queere
Aktionsplan einer Bundesregierung lange
hat er auf sich warten lassen
Schutt von der Straße schippen und
Löcher in Hausdächern Flicken dass hieß
es heute im Landkreis St wendel im
Saarland innerhalb weniger Sekunden
hatte gestern Nachmittag ein Tornado
deutliche Schäden verursacht Anbauten
wurden umgerissen Bäume entwurzelt
Dächer teilweise abgedeckt immerhin ist
es bei Sachschäden geblieben verletzt
wurde niemand
also noch zwei Tage Norbert dann beginnt
die umstrittene fußballwärmen Katar ja
zu der sich ja auch DFB-Präsident Bernd
Neuendorf mehrfach kritisch geäußert hat
auch heute wieder bei der
Pressekonferenz im deutschen Quartier
klare Worte aber nicht nur an die
Adresse des Gastgebers sondern auch an
die des Veranstalters der FIFA
FIFA Boss Gianni Infantino wird sich im
kommenden März zur Wiederwahl stellen
und das mangels anderer Kandidaten
voraussichtlich erfolgreich aus
Deutschland das machte DFB-Präsident
Bernd Neuendorf noch mal eindrücklich
klar gibt es dafür keine Unterstützung
insbesondere nach dem Schreiben von
Janine fantino in der vorletzten Woche
dass das Thema Menschenrechte jetzt
keine Rolle mehr spielen soll dass wir
uns jetzt hier auf den Fußball
konzentrieren das hat uns doch
einigermaßen irritiert auch verstört und
glaube da mussten wir jetzt dieses
Zeichen setzen ein weiteres Zeichen wird
der DFB mit dieser One Love
Kapitänsbinde setzen und lässt sich auch
von möglichen FIFA Sanktionen nicht
davon abhalten ich persönlich das sage
ich hier so offen
ich wäre durchaus bereit auch eine
Geldstrafe in Kauf zu nehmen und damit
ist der DFB nicht allein auch die
Engländer werden mögliche Strafen
akzeptieren
Nils Karten hat für uns diese
Pressekonferenz vor Ort beobachtet Nils
was sind deine Eindrücke
da saß ein Mann der sein humanistisches
Menschenbild nicht auf irgendeinem Basar
trägt einer dessen Höflichkeit nicht um
eine klare Meinung herumschleicht und
einer der auch ganz konkretes
mitgebracht hat eine Million Euro jetzt
geben von der Stiftung der
Nationalmannschaft für ein SOS
Kinderdorf in Nepal in dem Land also aus
dem die meisten der Gastarbeiter hier in
Katar kommen das ist eine ganz konkrete
Hilfe nichts gegen Slogans auf Trikots
oder die One Love kapitänsbünde von
Manuel Neuer oder transparente aber so
kommt Hilfe ganz genau da an wo Sie
bitte nötig gebraucht wird und sollte
sich die FIFA tatsächlich trauen diese
kapazitätsbinde zu sensionieren wir
haben es ja gerade den Beitrag gesehen
dann sagt Neundorf dann zahlen wir diese
Strafe gerne
danke Nils ja apropos FIFA die hat heute
eine durchaus spektakuläre Kehrtwende
vollzogen und auf Drängen von Katha den
Ausschank von Alkohol vor den Stadien
untersagt Bier gibt es nur alkoholfrei
einer der Hauptsponsoren dieser WM
bezeichnete diese Entscheidung als
peinlich
ja mal sehen ob noch andere gewichtigere
Vereinbarungen Kata gekippt werden und
was halten Sie von der wm-cutter sie
können mitdiskutieren in der heute live
gleich um 19:20 Uhr in der ZDF heute App
und auf Social Media
auf den Gipfeln im Allgäu ist da längst
gelandet der erste Schnee im flachen
Norden aber sind die zauberhaften
Eiskristalle schon noch etwas Besonderes
in Itzehoe Schleswig-Holstein reicht es
zumindest für eine zarte weiße Schicht
auf der A13 zwischen Brandenburg und
Sachsen waren die Flocken schon
ergiebiger und all das ist nur ein
Vorgeschmack darauf was zumindest Teile
der Republik in der Nacht und morgen
erwartet
wo genau der Schnee runterkommt das
erfahren Sie gleich im Bett davon besten
terli das heute journal können Sie um 22
Uhr sehen mit Christian Sievers schönen
Abend noch
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter diese
Luftmassengrenze existiert immer noch
quer über Deutschland und bringt
durchaus noch Schnee dieses Gebiet
verzieht aber nur relativ langsam in den
Süden der Film läuft bis morgen Abend
und Sie sehen ist es kommt nur wenig
südwärts voran ja und noch etwas
Schneefall gibt's Richtung Ostsee
durchaus auch mit Regen vermischt und
Graupel Gewitter sind auch mit im Gepäck
und in der Nacht also hier Regen und
teilweise sogar Schneefall auch in der
Mitte ist das der Fall und in diesem
schraffierten Bereich müssen sie mit
Glätte rechnen aber nicht nur durch
Schnee oder schneemaster sondern auch
mit überfrierender Nässe die
Temperaturen gehen im Nordosten auf bis
zu -7 Grad zurück sechs Grad Frost frei
im Südwesten das ist die Temperatur
Spanne ja und morgen dann im
Tagesverlauf zieht diese Schneegebiet
weiter südwärts und hier in der Mitte
müssen Sie komplette rechnen und auch
mal vielleicht Richtung Ostsee da fällt
durchaus auch Schnee dazwischen gibt es
viel Sonnenschein bei Temperaturen bis
10 Grad im Südwesten Dauerfrost Richtung
Osten bis -2 Grad und die nächsten Tage
ja weitere Schneefälle sind durchaus
dabei nach Osten in kälter als im
Südwesten bei 0 bis 10 Grad ein schöner
Abend